hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts evaluating the effectiveness
of training Animal Care and Use
personnel I'm Robert Castellanos of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this education web seminar presented
by lapid's and sponsored by locking the
laboratory animal welfare training
exchange is an organization of people
who train in and for the laboratory
animal science field by sharing ideas on
message and materials for training our
members can learn together how best to
meet the training and qualification
requirements of national regulations and
guidelines since 1994 our conferences
have been held every two years for
trainers to exchange information on
their training programs in the US and
abroad for more information please visit
lottie org we have a few important
announcements before we begin we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
many questions as we can via email
offline you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon and the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if any technical problems viewing
or sharing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
two and a button lower left I would like
to take this opportunity now to
introduce today's speaker dr. Melissa
Dyson dr. Melissa Dyson receipts from
veterinary degree from the University of
Tennessee College of Veterinary Medicine
and completed a residency in corporate
medicine at the University of Missouri
in conjunction with the research animal
diagnostic laboratories her clinical
research interests include laboratory
animal medicine management and
infectious disease she is the director
of the UM Training Corps and provides
educational programs for Animal Care and
news personnel I'll now turn it over to
the doctor for her presentation
or attending today as our moderator said
I'll be talking about evaluating the
effectiveness for training for Animal
Care and Use personnel so you know the
initial question is of course why do we
train and I think most of this in the
field have a lot of different reasons
that were interacting with Animal Care
and Use personnel and providing
educational programs some of the reasons
that are important to I think most of us
are often training is required by
regulations and guidelines we want to
promote humane and judicious use of
animals on making sure that the folks at
work with them are appropriately
prepared and confident we want to use
training to communicate information on
the institution's practices policies and
structure and we want to x'mas basic
level obviously provide employees the
necessary job skills so just to review
talk a little bit more detail about the
comments each of these regulations or
guides have on training we have
commentary or guidance from the US
government principles for the
utilization and Cara vertebrate animals
used in testing research and training
details are provided to us in the Animal
Welfare Act regulations and is a guide
for the care and use of laboratory
animals in the government principles it
indicated that investigators and other
personnel should be appropriately
qualified and experienced for conducting
procedures on animals and that
arrangement seemed to be made to have
training available including training on
the proper and humane care needs of
animals used in research programs the
Animal Welfare Act regulations also ask
that train be available to make sure
that individuals have access to
information on appropriate practices and
they provide additional detail including
information on what types of information
that you need to be provided information
on humane methods of animal maintenance
and experimentation information on the
concept of their mobility and use of
researcher testing methods that
limit the use of animals of minimize
pain and distress the appropriate use of
anesthetics analgesics and tranquilizers
for animal views in the facility methods
for reporting deficiencies or concerns
for animals use in the program the
utilization of services available to
provide information on methods and
alternative channels and Panama use an
app suggest is a guide you see a fairly
similar information provided training
needs to be available from four
individuals on Animal Care and Use
special legislation regulations and
guidance the iacocca options and
responsibilities ethics of animal use
and concepts of the three are methods
for recording concerns about animal use
occupational health and safety issues
and even system details on animal
handling of procrit a cyclical surgical
technique anesthesia analgesia and
euthanasia so the question is you know
at that level is training mandatory so
window from all our guidance that
personnel must be qualified and trying
to perform tasks associated with animals
and it kind of should be available and
must be documented so ultimately you
know we are guidance is telling us that
we need to make sure that people know
what they're doing training is often
that tool but accepting their competency
is a big part of that as well and I
think we see some of the standards of
how that can be practiced in how they
let program description ask questions to
us about describing the Animal Care news
program in our sights so when they let
program description under the training
education and continuing educational
opportunities section eric asked us to
describe how the i cook provides
oversight and evaluate the effectiveness
of training programs and the assessment
of personal competencies so training in
the assessment of competencies are
clearly joint um and in joint efforts in
effecting appropriate practices for
using animals and evaluating the
effectiveness effectiveness of those
programs is imperative to make sure that
the ultimate goal was
animal care news as it is performed
appropriately in focus sections
questions are asked with the veterinary
and animal care staff as well as the
research staff to describe training and
continuing educational opportunities
additionally the research team for the
research team typing of the training
mechanisms to ensure that train that the
research team has appropriate knowledge
and expertise and appropriate practices
are also listed into stuff so as we can
see from our regulations and standards
of practice our upper bowl is ensuring
that personnel are qualified and trained
to perform their tasks associated with
animals we can really use that as being
comprised of civil factors one is
appropriate and effective training and
the ayah cook is clearly tasked with
evaluating the training the
effectiveness of that training a partner
to that is competency assessment so when
providing training making sure that the
training is effective in promoting
competency or the staff that come with
experience are appropriately training
confident are important factors and then
of course the the partner of the I cook
and post-approval monitoring practices
to ensure that appropriate methods are
actually in place and utilized in the
animal facility in laboratories is real
real work life settings are an essential
piece of ensuring that training is
effective and it's being put into
practice where appropriate one of the
things that we'll be talking about today
is we go through some of the different
ways to evaluate training is the I cook
handbook survey so that I could handle
is a methodology next used surveys of
approximately 300 institutions using
animals in research across the United
States of those can vary from small to
large for maps from academia to industry
or pharmaceutical companies but in each
chapter and there are many chapters that
don't do with training in each chapter a
number of questions are posed to
respondent to get a feel for how people
are achieving appropriate training or
evaluating the effectiveness of training
across the field
I have the privilege of being able to
write and edit that chapter in the most
recent version so i'll be using a lot of
the results of that to talk about
practices that are in play across the
community as we go through this
presentation so how is the effectiveness
of training being evaluated out in the
field it's a little bit very lonesome
ocean vistas from 2012-2013 when the
manuals published but that's not that
long ago and it's really interesting to
see what people are struggling with as
we go through some of these surveys
important to note here that at the time
that these questions were posed about
forty-eight percent of those respondents
we're not using any metrics to evaluate
training there were other methodologies
so one institution could have added
answered yes to multiple of these
sections so twenty-nine percent of
respondents were using data reports from
post-approval monitoring assessment and
thirty-five percent of those were
actually doing data and reports from
work site assessments by individuals
like trainers I cook or animal care
center Airy staff so the torch we
utilize acceptance of programs that
there are a lot of metrics and data
being gathered and user life at that
time to evaluate the effectiveness of
training programs I think if the
challenge that we all face evaluation of
training to do we need is time consuming
and difficult to get really good
information on whether or not training
programs are proving effective and
ensuring that we have appropriate and
confident animal caring use the three
subject areas that I'm going to touch on
today are evaluating instructional
design evaluating learners and
evaluating instructors so evaluating
learners or evaluation of training by
and evaluating of learners it's probably
one of the most familiar areas that most
of us experience so evaluating how a
person's learned in class evaluating how
they're applying that inflammation but i
think the other parts of that program
include how training is designed
developed and implemented and given to
those learners and how many earth at our
instructors are actually able to
appropriately deliver information and
assess those learners most of us
probably came in to try
in the laboratory animal field by being
subject matter experts we're
veterinarians or trainers or animal care
staff solutely to an end up losing into
teaching others most of us don't have
educational backgrounds and so
developing skills trainer and designing
educational programs and evaluation
facial programs is a big area of growth
for us I think evaluating how we do that
on a regular basis helps improve the
training programs that have been
delivered to learners so let's start
with instructional design this is one of
many many examples of instructional
design systems and programs that you can
find I like this system because it's
simple and you lastimosa that's not
really ready to jump in to complex texts
on how to design instructional materials
coming from a subject matter expert
background but i think the spiritual
guidance to those of us working in this
field are nearly breaking down and
thinking of developing training
materials in a logical manner from and
analyzing the need for training
developing and designing that trains
implementing and evaluating training
another way to look at this design model
is thinking of evaluation as a key point
or cornerstone in the process so whether
you're doing the analysis for the needs
of training and designing developing or
even implementing the delivering
training incorporating evaluation if
each of these levels was really
important and valuable so that you're
preventing the states along the way and
then as those continuing your running
training classes on a regular basis
continuing to evaluate the effectiveness
of that training with the delivery of
that training can be pretty important
okay so let's jump into analysis really
quickly you know you really have to
start with global here what is our
ultimate goal for all of our training
programs insurance personnel are
qualified and trained to perform tasks
associated with animals as we talked
about earlier so effective training is
going to be key competency assessment
and department to expecting the
appropriate delivery of materials and
post a free home monitoring as we
earlier are all important factors so one
of the things are like to point out at
this point is that obviously trains very
important to me in all of us and it's an
extremely important component of an
animal care programmer of any work site
educational programs but it's not a
solution to all problems I think even
before an analysis of what we need to
train our is performed analyzing whether
train is my answer is extremely
important performance issues tend to be
multifactorial so if we have a little
bit of individuals that not performing
this function correctly say you have
individuals who are not putting dirty
changing in the appropriate place
assuming that that is a training issue
before analyzing what's going wrong in
that scenario maybe you don't have
appropriate rats available for placement
of dirty cages maybe maybe do a lot to
sort facility areas and telling
investigators personality to be using
them so personnel management program
management issues are all is as potent
as training when you're analyzing a
problem the trainees announces an
important thing and even a performance
analysis to make sure that our
performance problem is really related to
lack of knowledge and not other
performance safety issues so moving back
to instructional design in our adding
model some of the main pieces in the
design in the development phase involves
making sure that you know and the person
or the person who's developing your
training knows what they should be
training on who they're teaching and who
should be giving the training how to
deliver training admit to deliver
training and all these factors we often
just assume when we're putting together
training materials however really
analyzing and evaluating if your answers
answering these questions correctly and
going back and reevaluating these
questions when you reevaluate the value
where your training program can really
highlight some areas of weakness that
maybe need to be updated to be most
effective so question of contents of a
lot of materials and information
available obviously they're going to be
directed by people
Owen work tasks we do have a lot of
guidance because we discussed in the
animal welfare place and the guide we
have a lot of subject matter experts
around the people in cage wash know how
to do page wash your research staff and
your veterinarians and technicians know
how to do a lot of the animal procedures
that are around so consulting with
damage you're developing training is
very important but there are some of
those publications and resources out
there to help guide that that I think
can be used to develop training but also
nuisance told to evaluate training
that's in play to make sure that we're
continuing to meet both the regulatory
and standard of practice of requirements
for your training programs so both of us
are probably familiar with the guide
that the NRC put out 1991 family day is
this still a really good introductory
premise to training materials for the
laboratory animal community it's
entitled the education and training in
the can use of laboratory animals it is
a guidebook that includes curriculum and
recommendations for training on
regulations legislation animal use and
even specific species use and surgery
needs you have been many platforms would
have grown out of this information and
once again and its really dabassisst at
that time most training was very focused
on training the research team and there
wasn't a whole lot of information really
thought through about training the
veterinarians to animal care staff is
because all those allied groups and such
things is really grown and developed in
a lot of other directions since then in
2007 Iowa put out enough Vegas volume
with the summary is a 91 guide as well
as summaries of new training and
learning strategies papers and articles
on training for the eyes took animal
care staff lots of those other program
areas that really welcomed those
concepts further along the I approached
handbook that I mentioned earlier i
think is a crazy source not only for
training but many other aspects of
oversight of the Animal Care and Use and
the diet cook may be responsible for for
those of you who aren't familiar that a
class with the American Association of
light rain
science it's one of the pre-eminent
organizations within laboratory animal
medicine and science they actually host
the Learning Library as many many online
courses available some for free that you
can you like to educate yourself or
utilize for your whole educational
program at each institution and some of
those modules are is actually also
customizable so that's a valuable link
to build visits if you're looking at
bringing training into your program
especially online training unsteady the
collaborative inter-institutional
training initiative is a similar program
that provides the online training
resources that can be used for our
institutions other lastly of course I
would be remiss if I didn't mention our
program sponsor today the laboratory
animal welfare training exchange or lock
a at locking doors as our moderator
discussed latte is an organization that
promotes animal welfare through
effective training and educational
programs for animal research
professionals so trainers from all over
get together and share ideas share
method that could be part of the
exchanges our programs or membership in
this organization allows you access to
this exchange access to list serves
where you can interact with trainers
from other areas and share ideas and
learn we also have our biennial
conference that occurs every two years
this year that will be hosted in Hershey
Pennsylvania by the Penn State Hershey
Medical Center we will be focusing on
teaching learning and supporting animal
welfare and that will be jun 13 to 16 in
hershey it's going to be a great time i
think we're going to learn a lot we're
going to network a lot and of course
they'll be lots of great chocolate they
already sent us a lot to get ready for
the program so if you're interested
please please consider joining us
alright so he talks a lot about what
it's a simple different areas and now
it's going to jump into the zoo of who
were training and what can you do
simulate thinking about both developing
training programs and evaluating
existing programs are we giving the
right information to the right
individuals so initially when training
became more more important 11th or
animal field trained for the research
team was too
so what everyone was thinking about how
do we make sure that the scientists or
their staff understands how to
appropriately perform procedures and
research animals but as we've gone well
obviously we all realize that training
for Isis members and all animal care
staff even occupational health and sexy
information needs to be passed on to all
these individuals so ultimately anyone
who worked with or is responsible for
work with animals who lurks an animal
support areas with animal kvm tissues or
even a regulatory matter need some level
of education so that they understand
institutional expectations and
appropriate standards of practice so
we're going to jump into another one of
these surveys here from the handbook
because I think it's really easy to just
so lift that on telephone and say all
these people need to be trained I think
all of you know if you're doing this in
your programs are ready you're facing
these questions or evaluating your
programs these questions are always so
simple there's lots of what about this I
need a special or different
consideration why should I have to pay
training look at that experience because
I'm only working a small amount of time
so it's valuable to see me surveys from
other places to see some of the details
that some of us are struggling with to
make sure that we are comprehensively
applying educational program to everyone
that reads them across institutions so
these are some of the questions that you
may want to ask yourself when evaluating
your training program and its
effectiveness in as comprehensive nature
so the question that was posed to survey
respondents peers new principal
investigators who will not be performing
animal work have to partake in an
institutional Animal Care new training
program so in in Scenario a laboratory
director who is responsible for grants
and responsible for all the research
going on in the laboratory may not been
so Leslie do many hands on worth of
animals so does your program requires a
day paid training so thirty-seven
percent of respondents here visit days
yes that they require principal
investigators our laboratory directors
to take the same training as fast to
perform the procedures even if they
aren't doing that hands-on work why is
about thirty-five percent in two
individuals say only basic training is
required more detailed train is not
required and around 320
twenty-two percent say there's no
additional training of any kind is
required at all now if the results of
these surveys are not intended to show
you right along their intended to make
you think about the different types of
areas that you need to evaluate consider
when you're looking at these questions
on you need to take training in your
institution the second question if a
person has successfully completed
training in a different institution
should I cook at the new institution
your institution require machinery take
a similar of course at your institution
or otherwise demonstrate her
capabilities so for example you have a
new scientist converse with mice in
research for 20 years and you want them
to take the introductory to mouth
training course is that required at your
program so sixty-six percent of
respondents says it varies with
circumstances that they can waive some
training requirements twenty-nine
percent said that they never wave
training requirements I know our
institution has recently moved into that
philosophy and they feel that for our
institution there are a number of
specific standards of practice or
methodologies for adhering to
requirements that they feel are in close
enough that anyone coming into the
institution working with animals have to
take all the training available or have
a competency assessment thirdly can
someone with experience in surgery
anesthesia in human patients perform
these procedures on animals without
additional training or competency
assessment so for example of human
surgeon who's used to doing an effective
me or kidney removal in a human wants to
fulfill that procedure in a rabbit will
be required to dictate additional
training forty-one percent of
respondents said no they don't require
no they don't allow this person to
perform procedures without additional
training so the investigator would have
to take rabbit surgery or some
combinations that type of training
twenty-three percent of respondents and
yes we might make make them take
training but we're valuing each request
line case by case basis so it may depend
on the web organization is
responsibility that individual has to
actual animal welfare care and use
alright students working with live
animals during a class be required to
participate in an animal use training
program so this is obviously much more
focus on an academic setting but we may
have large numbers of students 300 in
some cases taking a questioning of
semesters that many involve some blood
work interaction with an animal maybe
it's just observing rats romanians
involves animals surgeries at a teacher
is actually overseeing so in this
scenario thirty-four percent of
respondents and course instructors
provide training to students in the
course rather than the animal program
next ten percent of respondents
indicated that students and courses
receive the same or similar training as
that provided to research personnel
depending on your institution this could
be a pretty hefty number of classes to
be able to interact with an animal so
once again this is not a rise along
survey it is valuable to see how other
people are achieving or answering these
questions for their programs that you
are evaluating how comprehensive or
effective your training is your ultimate
goal all right does your eyes cook
require that short-term personnel for
example summer students visiting
professors etc complete to save the
training requirements as full-time
investigators and staff so for example
maybe you have a professor that's coming
in for tuning to do a short-term project
or demonstrated procedure to a
collaborator lab at your institution in
this scenario but seventy-nine percent
response the respondent says short-term
employers have to feel the same training
requirements and if that takes two weeks
in a row here for two weeks they can't
do work with an open till they finish
them I can be pretty extensive on twelve
percent of respondents indicated that
short-term employees have somewhat
modified training requirements so maybe
they're going to come for a short period
of time and make it one modified module
can only work with supervised
experienced staff something like that
okay lastly if a person from another
institution of commercial organization
is to demonstrate how to perform a
procedure on a live animal how can the
iscope
that person is qualified to perform the
procedure so in next scenario maybe you
have a representative of a company
coming in and showing over the
physicians how to use their product in a
pink surgery not the third one percent
of respondents didn't have this
experience is something we certainly see
in academic into these forty four
percent of respondents that that they
reviews with written qualifications of
that individual and twenty-four percent
accepted written statements from the
principal investigator where is
twenty-nine percent survey actually a
veterinarian watch the person proponent
of the feature and that veterinarian
makes off the procedure if it's
inappropriate now remember that which
once can answer in the positive because
more than one of these questions of some
people they be doing vote once again
these may be small groups of what goes
on your institution that they're all
participants in the animal care news
programs and evaluation of the decisions
made each of these levels is important
okay so we talked a lot about the
welcome to designers develop designing
and developing training programs let's
talk a little bit about the how so also
different ways to deliver training I
think we're all pretty aware of that
it's going to vary the subject matter
with those resources that you have
available with your needs it accepts
from doing all sort of online computer
based courses there's lots of value in
those you can directly to lots of people
at lots of different times you can
document them easily you can implement
quizzes and evaluations with online on
training modules in our own internal
assessments for our program we actually
do post online course assessments in
workshop classes unfortunately we're
finding that a large number of
individuals don't detain a great deal of
information from computer based courses
by the time they walk in the door is a
new person are overwhelmed with the
large amount of each other visit given
by the time they get to a hands-on
practice they don't remember a lot of
that inflammation so continuing
education programs or workshop and
hands-on courses following online
courses may be a better way to capture
it and keep the information that you
need is to have long-term lectures and
seminars are also very valuable there
are obviously more time in 10
there's per person for the information
you want to transmit there's no way I
think that we can never replace the
value of workshops or hands-on courses
especially if you're teaching an
individual a physical skill that they
have to learn and then demonstrate
however those are fairly time intensive
and those utilizing partners in that
beyond the trainer's veterinarians and
even the research personnel that may be
appropriately experience or lose ways to
capitalize on the diversity of
experience in the community another big
question here I think when you're
evaluating your training program is no
matter the format of the courses
addressing the needs of the learners so
in the short term design but also in
sort of series of how adults learn in
the workplace I think many of us not
being trained in educational communities
don't always have a feel for what that
means to the adult learner in the
workplace we'll talk a little bit about
that more later in the presentation okay
so another foreigners who should provide
training was indifferent folks and what
they took places some staff trainers to
veterinarians that I cook staff and even
occupational health and safety personnel
are teaching people things all over the
place we'll talk more about this a
little bit later as well by then and I
mentioned both of us are trained as
educators and so evaluating how you
ensure that those delivering information
are able to do so effectively is very
important so who provides training at
institutions across the country looks
like we have about seventy four percent
of respondents the animal care staff
technician supervisors and veterinarians
are a big part of that training programs
we talked about this slide a little
earlier as well I took staff about
seventeen percent extra stage only about
thirty percent of people had a dedicated
training program personnel I think that
was growing even in small institutions
now because of the emphasis and
importance on regular conference of
training and documenting and valuation
of that training okay finally win
another piece important piece of that
before implementing is deciding
when we need to happen so this is
equation post in the handbook must
personality train before a research
project begins if you percent of
respondents here said that in most
instances the person must have basic
skills needed before the project begins
but more detailed skills can't be gained
during the course of the project and
then thirty-three percent said in most
instances a person must be fully trained
and i've been working at our guidance
and the questions in the AI program
description making sure that people are
trained before they are actually
applying procedures and working with
animals or what he and the job site is
extremely important and i think this is
a this can be challenging trying to get
everybody in the door trying to persuade
before their relational systems and then
allowing us to track and do continuing
education as an additional person there
so in the survey we also asked what are
the consequences of failure to complete
the prior training by the principal
investigator or members of the research
team so various things occur and most
often of protocol in approval is limited
for completion of training or personnel
restricted from performing procedures of
getting into facilities such as the same
dental training is complete we found in
our experience without a hog stop
preventing people from doing their work
in an academic environment we would
generally have Western seventy percent
compliance with training requirements so
most people have done at this point
without hog thoughts for training
requirements it's difficult to control
so you know evaluating your program and
you do not have high rates of compliance
or Bill Gates of compliance with your
training requirements you know
evaluating that system and creating some
power stops within that system to
prevent people from moving forward
without completing training I think most
of us have found is pretty important to
making sure training is done properly
also what interval is periodic
retraining of animal chitters requires
so this is continuing education and as
we saw when you look at some sample
questions that they let program
description continuing education is
being quite emphasized so at this time
we had about thirty one percent of
assignments that this was my apple
so there was no continuing education
twenty-four percent of respondents were
doing continued education every 30 or
greater and then it varies beyond that
so I think that's important to look at
obviously every three years is sort of a
natural cycle for us because it mimics
the cycle of a protocol approval and
it's a valuable time to create a stop it
which you can graph graph folks and
require that they complete training let
it as we found in some of our own
evaluations is we have people retain any
less than fifty percent of what they're
getting from just completion of online
modules continuing education is
extremely important not only to try to
continue to educate them to the process
of their work cycle but also to make
sure that they are up with new standards
as we know policies and institutional
practices to hazard continual process of
change those you're evaluating a
training program in this aspect looking
at continuing education is value and
effect on compliance and knowledge as a
whole is pretty important so what
question are used by your institution to
indicate as I specific individual
requires more training so beyond just
standard required training are the ways
in which we will need to evaluate look
at how do we how do you mean do we need
to recommend that someone gets more so
sixty-five percent 75-cent folks are
looking at non compliance report or
supervisor or TI recommendation and then
51% are reporting poor performance on
post training evaluation processes pans
competency evaluation those types of
things having the ability for a trainer
to say you know what you haven't you
haven't done this appropriately you need
to go back to a training having those
processes worked out and the line upon
can be a pretty important factor if you
don't have the ability for a tremor or
supervisor the figures individuals not
performing their appropriately and we
need to go back to training those got a
big gap in the effectiveness of our
training program is no other side of
that okay so we talked about evaluation
of instructional design now I'm going to
jump into evaluation of learners so
Becca said this is probably the most
familiar areas evaluation at most of us
experience
the evaporation of training by dollars
and the evaluation of the trans effect
on those learners you can look at this
in a simple manner in four different
levels one supporting for one easiest
absorbing the most complex together at
the same time the level one types of
training maybe the data we gather from
those types of evaluations are impactful
even though they introduced and this
gives a lot of a lot of great
information about what people are
gathering from the training classes in
our tools to this predator look at sort
of do we have problems with
instructional design we have problems
that we need to optimize with healthful
rhetoric training those types of things
okay so about hitting reaction we gather
this info by asking people immediately
or posts or a little further down the
road post training how to train and go
you need to make sure that evaluation
methodologies ask what you want to know
that it well designed and encouraged
completed honest responses like I said
these are easy quick in their valuable
so you can put the other metrics of this
information however they can be pretty
subjective and you're not a hoe
knowledge game for us and we don't know
how many schools and inflammation at the
worm retains ultimately contention these
types of evaluations are you know people
short focus on your objectives only ask
about things exchange incorporate
clothes any questions you know how would
you get this class 125 those sorts of
things are very valuable yes and then
types of answers tend to be difficult to
follow up on too many too many
interruptions overwhelming you also
might tell all your learners that you
value this feedback and encouragement to
provide it and make sure that those
funds are anonymous so that they can
feel comfortable providing that I think
some really big pieces of this or that
not only be need to assess the results
regularly so we have a trainer from
using after every class but also assess
them in a group and in summary
methodology if this semi-annual
the great times of that for really
looking at you know we get in all five
everything's great or releasing in
certain classes that certain evaluations
I'm coming through well and why are we
having this problems and what our plans
are fix them we also reevaluate the form
and methodology itself regularly so if
you have sort of this evaluation
methodology going and you look back over
six months and say you know why every
time we give this class we get psych on
everything we get no valuable
information from this method man wanna
change your method of evaluation to try
to get better information okay so local
people going to happen to evaluate
learning different ym seems very simple
but we know it can be very complex to to
really assess how much people were taken
in a long term so we can use past before
an asset evaluation is even more
valuable so the value of people know
beforehand compared to what they gained
after the training program simulations
and demonstrations can also be really
valuable to rule so if you're learning a
methodology e-learning and de practice
you're doing IP injection in mind having
the person be able to demonstrate that
appropriately can be a great evaluation
of their competency in the practice what
I think that we have learned those
evaluations we use evaluations going to
evaluate learners but also to evaluate
our course delivery and content is that
if we tell individuals they don't have
to put their name on the evaluation that
we're actually using this tool to test
our own timing they're much more
comfortable answering questions so we
actually use a lot of pre and
post-testing in those methodologies to
get a general census the learning that
goes on and the effect of the search
rules rather than acquainting
individuals so what the other was is a
great way to demonstrate what they learn
in the immediate scenario on the other
hand it doesn't really guarantee the
application of the work site it's
certainly a step in the right direction
though in this information can be very
valuable it can't it can lend itself
into metrics and data that you can
easily prevent prevent to your I cook or
your animal program oversight body so
that they can feel that
training programs are being evaluated
and assessed on with those tools once
again as we mentioned you'd be
evaluating for the learners response
affecting your results regularly and
assessing the methods that you need to
get those results regularly is really
important to keep a continual process of
self evaluation and treatment going so
evaluating behavior this is level three
we're stepping up into the next level we
did a lot of good information from this
methodology but it's time and resource
intensive these Auto allow time for
behavior change so someone's going to
apply what we taught them differently a
week after training immersive six weeks
to a year goes to the work site to see
actually how people performing the fun
dysfunction is training the lawn that
can be done by trainers post-approval
monitoring staff even supervisors what's
important here is that everyone has the
same context of what the expectations
are so that the data that you get back
is consistent valuable so you can even
create a sec mature evaluating teenager
that all of those different teams have
available so they turn workplace
assessment second you have detailed
information that you can follow on what
pieces were lacking in workplace
application related to training as I
mentioned this is on one hand the truth
assessment activities and results of
learning from your training it's time in
fact intensive but i do think if you put
work into consistent expectations and
even form formats for feedback you can
actually get better information here you
can also feel intrusive to staff and
interrupt both processes so someone
knows you're evaluating them they may
change or follow procedures in a more
detail and enables otherwise the last
level there is evaluating behavior or
sorry is evaluating result so that's
waiting how the training program has had
an effect on the compliance and welfare
and practices in your program as a whole
this is very valuable takes a lot of
time to design to capture so one of the
mistakes that we have certainly made
program is trying to capture this
information too late in the game so if
you really want to evaluate result to
return on investment of a training
program you have to design your data
capture methodologies to capture
baseline data before a change occurs so
if you want to see if you can improve
compliance with a set of surgical
practices inter-facility you really want
a good feel for how aseptic physical
processes are now you want metrics and
measurable data so a check sheet on how
many times people aren't using
appropriate disinfectants encore are so
unfair pet unicorn breaking trail
technique and surgery if you can
actually break those things down get an
analysis of what's going on that wins
the resultant of your training program
and if you can use those same questions
to evaluate change in that program and
it takes a lot of foresight to plan the
sorts of evaluations and in the long
term but there's a really great
assessment tools to capture how well
training has changed a program a culture
that was challenging in the first place
so you know you want to make sure that
you have to go we'll design and it is
the metric she went to captures was
beginning to the end of the project and
also knows that the tanks are returned
to the affected by manufacturers that
may not just be training you just the
fact that you're evaluating people may
change their behavior and the fact that
they're getting evaluated main in itself
being a reminder and culture change tool
in addition to just a training program
okay so we're looking at this very
interested but and looking at this we
have we do have some survey results from
the hand look so it's part of the
training program for your annual
county's problem is any form of
evaluation assessment or texting
utilized so it varies we have 50 face
fifty-eight percent of respondents
saying a demonstration of competency is
required during training sessions
forty-four percent says that were cut
evaluation of competency let supervisory
personnel is employees and so he eight
percent are just get
Sam so those may be the same
organizations as well and sixteen
percent are doing your testing so
obviously it's quite diverse and I think
as we look more and more value a shin of
training using all of those different
levels of tools whether they're post
training evaluations examinations during
or after a class community
demonstrations and works on evaluations
they're all very important pieces of
evaluating training the best way to look
at the effectiveness in training is
designed captures capture methodologies
for data in a way that you can really
look at a summary and retrospective of
what's been happening to get a feel for
how effective the program is in
implementation okay lastly I'm going to
talk a little bit about without waiting
instructors so we talked a little bit
about this earlier we have providing
training we have a creative ursa group
and we looked at this survey the survey
results fairly recently earlier in the
presentation veterinarians animal care
staff supervisors managers I took staff
research personality because some areas
designated training personnel are
teaching people also to various pieces
of information most of those thoughts
are educators and so making sure that we
have the right tool to train those
trainers and then any kind using those
tools to evaluate the effectiveness the
most trainers are important tools to
improving your program and evaluating
your trainers and getting them that kind
of goes for improving their own work
status of efficiency so look a little
bit about transitioning from a subject
matter expert to a trainer adult
learning theories instructional design
education for trainers and then making
sure trainers know how to evaluate their
own training so subject matter expertise
is something most of us have whether
you're really great at surgery or you
know how to change an applications or we
work in the Iowa caucus and that's a
really important part of what you do
what we find though is that specialize
an expert don't always transfer your
information to others very
either League so you may select the
person in your staff it's best that
deleting IP injections in life it may
not be very effective at training others
in doing that one of the organizations
that I've been very helpful in starting
out a new trainer with some great tools
to learn how to teach is an organization
that used to be called the American
Society of training development I EST de
but is now called the Association for
talent development or TV and I call it
AFP d because many of the references
that i provide are actually in their old
format so they provide educational
programs conferences and have a number
of publications that i've been very
valuable their focus on the workplace
education and development marcus like a
trained animal science but some of their
train the trainer programs have little
bit excellent tools for us so
instructional development for trainers
mark Faris course design is really
essential own really focusing developing
training materials and what the learner
needs to know and how the learner needs
to know it's really important and I
think most of us and subject matter
experts really think more about how the
understand something been how's the
learner least understand it for example
experts often provide interesting yet
non-essential information to overload
the learner so there's a lab member we
need to know when all the amendments to
the Animal Welfare Act regulations
occurred in what they contained I
seriously doubt that information is
valuable to their appropriate can use of
animals in the research setting it's
overwhelming to them and it takes up
space in your training program it's not
valuable even though it may be really
fascinating to you if you're working
with regulations all the time how does
the student learn so experts tender
group information and large chunks and
novices if I'm explaining to you how to
give a 90 injection and the mouth I may
tell you and three steps referring the
mouth get your new job put the mouse's
head down and inject a funk lately there
could be 15 to 20 different steps within
that system that a novice does not
understand and until you understand how
to break those down and appropriately
organize a consistent manner you're
training your learner is going to be
quite lost and maybe an expert in an
area you make
transmitting that to them appropriately
Adult Learning also the Syrians pedagogy
an idea that don't sound differently
then children can be very important as
well especially for those of us who
don't have educational backgrounds so is
ignoring is the process of personalizing
information training on the other hand
is the process of helping students make
those connections and personalizing that
information there are some theories that
they adult have different ways of
learning their children and it's
important for educators to notice when
they're designing and delivering
training in the professional setting so
some of the principles they'll talk
about our adult really want to know why
they're learning something and
interacting that as part of training
both of the individual and their
supervisor can be truly valuable in the
attitude that they bring to training and
what they're willing to take out of it
adults also have a repository of
lifetime experiences so they want
novices in life and they may come with
most good and bad experiences in
whatever procedure that you're trying to
teach them about acknowledging that to
be very helpful with evolving
relationship with them and opening them
up to learning from you and you also may
learn about information that they have
this novel to you or about why they're
having some challenges an area that
you're trying to get them to move
towards adults also really like to use
hands on problem solving for learning so
memorization of facts and features is
not going to help nor that really
effective to work site applications so
applying this knowledge and skills
giving your quizzes giving them a chance
to discuss training giving you a chance
to demonstrate my phaser skills very
important if you look back at your
training program when you're evaluating
it and you're not incorporating some of
these I've use until how you develop and
implement and provide training programs
that there's a concern and you may need
to reevaluate some of them okay so some
other things to think about is getting a
chance to discuss prior experiences and
converse and ask questions about your
information getting the chance to
self-assess i did it i don't get it a
natural health if they need it
reflecting on those prior experiences
and
practicing these skills whenever
necessary i SPECT hot this trainer you
make you sure that they understand how
to self-evaluate so a lot of what we
have talked about throughout this
presentation has been knowing how to
develop training knowing how to develop
learners creating forms programs to
gather data on evaluation close if your
time y'all you as a trainer don't really
understand how to utilize those tools or
even to evaluate the success of a class
that is developed some of that can be
lost so even some of the simple features
of did the coach run smoothly where the
timelines appropriate the students
respond appropriately with folks
sleeping in class or the asking
questions we actually address some of
these with large teams trainers we have
so many people providing the same types
of courses at different times we
appreciate templates from the contents
activity provided say in a class about
the use of hazards or in a class about
the handling of a raft and vary within
each of those are actually questions
that they have proposed through the
learners at certain times to make sure
the learners are paying attention to
emphasize certain points and give those
adult learners a chance to really
stinking social flecked on what they've
learned so far in the course we find
those to be really valuable tools it's
another thing to think about in
educating your trainers on how to self
evaluate the students can't expected
skills and knowledge so if your trainer
not experiencing they have not developed
in their training program that's at all
these methodologies to evaluate learning
and learners as part of their process
that something that needs to be
implemented and then establishing
competency and proficiency standards
clearly this is one of the most direct
way is evaluating the competency of an
individual after a learning experience
is one of the clearest and death ways to
evaluate the effectiveness of that
training what we found in athletic
trainer go and tell them evaluate
competency before you graduate civil
from this class if they don't understand
how to develop a confidence p standard
they're not effective at that
methodology because if you read the
literature or ask training professionals
how they evaluate competency if the
answer is on the damage
many possibilities a lot of people use
the idea that if person can demonstrate
a perfect and a procedure appropriately
1 2 3 times they're given a competency
path but if your trainer doesn't have
any experience in that the education on
how and what are the factors that should
be evaluated for competency helping them
develop those tools thinking through
when I restraining the mouth of picking
an animal up from ok to what all the 10
different things I need to think about
that happen appropriately the fact that
the animals comfortable with the animals
health is evaluated that we're
remembering to wear gloves all those
sorts of things are the new layers of
detail that needs to be thought through
the developing competency standards that
you need to evaluate make sure that your
trainers understand how to apply ok so
we've talked about lots of stuff we
talked about transitioning trainers from
subject matter experts educators adult
learning theories making sure they
understand instructional design and
evaluating evaluation methodologies so
way you can clusion we talked about a
lot of stuff today in a lot of different
areas there are many levels of
evaluation beyond just the traditional
methodologies of tests and works on
assessment although those are very
important tools and I think can lend
themselves to metrics and methodologies
of looking at the effectiveness of your
programs ultimately our goal is to
ensure that personnel are qualified and
trained to perform tasks associated with
animals I think you know in the final
thought as I mentioned earlier training
to be viewed as an important component
of an animal care program and so the
beginning of any evaluation is beginning
with the effective means for training as
a solution at all I wish you all good
luck with your training programs and
please view at the moderator know if you
have any questions for me or about the
presentation have a great day
I like to thank dr. Dyson again for that
outstanding presentation I want to
remind our audience you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and again all
questions are going to be answered via
email I also like to thank our sponsor
lucky for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand dealing through
April 2017 you'll receive an email some
lab roots alerting me when that webcast
is available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and until next time goodbye
you